Gala was held tonight bringing awareness
to human sex trafficking and as you're
about to hear the crime is all too
common particularly here in Nevada
Madison Kimbra was at the event and
spoke to Gala organizers she joins us
live in our Newsroom tonight with more
Madison human trafficking is one of the
fastest growing crimes in our country in
Las Vegas ranks number one in the nation
for trafficking of minors that's
according to the B.A Shiro foundation
and tonight they hosted a Gala to bring
awareness to the issue
this is everyone's problem this is not a
female problem this is not a not
necessarily just a male problem this is
a human problem and so everyone needs to
be involved the biashiro foundation
hosting their eighth annual sex
trafficking awareness Gala bringing
awareness to the growing crime an issue
we unfortunately see too much of here in
Las Vegas Nevada currently has the
second highest rate of human trafficking
in the country per 100 000 people
according to impactnevada.org Metro's
assistant Sheriff Sasha Larkin shares
with 8 news now just how prevalent it
can be around us because it's not
something that happens in a foreign land
it's not something that happened and to
other people everybody is susceptible
since the girl next door it's your own
child that gets lured online it's
something that happens at school or at
the mall right by a boy that they think
they love or it can be any number of
scenarios and with the be a Shiro
Foundation founder Kimberly miles says
the amount of organization she's now
partnered with is growing because the
need is ongoing we can't wait for
somebody else to do something it has to
be local people which makes it
contagious for each community and we
have one of our organizations opening a
third house we have another organization
that just started champions for Casa
what's happening in Casa is we have over
3 600 homeless kids in a program foster
care
and proceeds from tonight's event will
support the foundation's program for
housing medical and counseling services
for survivors plus Education and
Training for the prevention and
intervention of sex trafficking in The
Newsroom Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now